salut c'est la suite de la vidéo de
vendredi où là il ya les tickets en
train de se cacher parce que je vais
faire une prédiction autour de la
prédiction que m'avait fait élire
vendredi
je vais faire une prédiction disons que
je vais faire çà çà çà çà
et voilà ça c'est ma prédiction dans
quelques secondes vous allez voir ce que
je vais faire à laitiers mon but c'est
ça si vous n'avez pas vu la vidéo de
vendredi est évidemment regardé l'avant
mais si on est dans une autre ligue
c'est parce qu'on avait rendez vous au
parc des buttes chaumont pour faire les
deux vidéos et qui pleut à mort il n'ya
pas un bar à côté donc on s'est trouvé
sa solution de repli c'est un chouette
studio est donc ainsi de la vidéo je
suis en face et derrière la voiture
c'est n'importe quoi en ce moment avec
les petits tas dilutif salle des
familles
est ce que tu es heureuse de donner
notre vie pour faire une vidéo avec moi
franchement plus improbable un super g
en temps je suis désolé j'ai honte de
moi
en fait nos rangs plus des banques j'ai
donc préparé une prédiction du dos de la
prédiction des lits c'est ici que mr
vous l'avez toi tu l'as pas vu on est
d'accord et j'ai avec moi un jeu de
cartes esp donc ses 25 ans tu connais le
carton esp pour faire très rapide en
fait c'est des symboles hier cinq
symboles différents qui sont répétés
cinq fois croix carré et toi alexis tard
c'était sur le travail du docteur rinne
qui faisait un travail sur l'étude
parapsychologiques et est né en 1930 a
décidé d'en faire des jeux de cartes
comme ça pour tester la sensibilité
parapsychologiques des gens comme toi tu
es empathie quand on devrait pouvoir
faire des trucs avec ça on va essayer du
moins que se passe-t-il alors du coup il
nous faudrait une table comme on a pas
de table heureusement on a des sièges et
on a des petites jambes et moi je suis
très grand tu vas donner les cartes
comme ça ok mais tu t'arrêtes de quand
tu veux te voit obligé de donner tout le
paquet donc tu continues à les données
des cantons mama retard est ok ça s'est
terminé
donc ça c'est ce qu'on n'utilisera pas
faire une espèce de configuration un
espèce de petit triangle
ah là là on voit pas les cartes mon
vieux tu sais quoi je te donne l'écran
ah ouais alors on recommence du coup
nous on recommence pas mais juste
juste pour que vous sachiez à la donner
autant de cartes qu'elle voulait après
la diviser à peu près en deux temps et
les cartes qui restent et on les a mis à
voter ça va je dis pas de bêtises
là on voit que nos mains c'est ça un peu
les jambes et un peu les jambes c'est
formidable on va sélectionner cinq
cartes parce que j'ai mis 5 arte sur ma
prédiction
on va les positionner au fur à mesure tu
me dis juste à chaque fois si tu veux
qu'on prenne ce paquet là aussi tu veux
qu'on prenne ce paquet c'est bien
d'accord voilà et on va faire ça cinq
fois d'affilée donc celui là où c'est
lui à chaque fois tu là parce que j'ai
ramené la maman nancy et suis là pour
terme ce qui nous fait un rond auront
une étoile un carré et une croix vois ça
c'est les cartes qui restent et des
rondes et ont une étoile des machins
carte tu as fait ça au hasard on est
d'accord oui venez pas complices non je
ne savais pas ça j'ai peur
la prédiction vous l'avez vu par contre
toi tu l'as pas vu la prédiction j'ai
juste fait une petite configuration de
cartes potentiel avec une forme
géométrique qui pouvait potentiellement
donner un cercle un cercle une étoile à
carhaix et une croix toi qu'on applaudit
mais merde on est one carré car ils
croient croiser mais non on a donc
maintenant se brouiller puisque quand on
considère tous toute la team menthe à
l'eau considère que maintenant tu es une
sorcière
ils peuvent vip elle était sûre ça va ça
t'a plu oui c'était génial franchement
merci beaucoup d'être venu jusqu'ici
pour tourner dans une auto lib et là on
est en train de terminer les deux vidéos
et commence arrêté de pleuvoir tout à
fait normal ce sont les mamies et sa
poisse et c'est mamie sort non c'est
juste la poisse et avant qu'on monte
dans le clip de lady à tous les coups
c'est ce qui va se passer
merci à vous d'avoir regardé la vidéo si
ça vous a plu n'hésitez pas à nous
laisser un généreux pouce en l'air ou
3,3 alors il faut tour non un nombre
impair c'est important parce que sinon
si tu mets deux salles landaise
voilà trois c'est bien 3 5 7
dans quelques jours je vous fais une
annonce sur la chaîne sur ce qui va se
passer cet été dans quelques jours c'est
à dire jeudi en fait c'est à dire après
demain parce que je suis en train de
penser en même temps que je vous parle
donc après demain je vous fais une
annonce pour ce qui va se passer cet été
sur la chaîne n'hésitez pas à regarder
ça c'est très important laitiers
également j'ai oublié de vous dire elle
fait du cosplay du super cosplay tu as
des super photo d'ailleurs sur facebook
avec ton armure et c'est avec eux qu'on
peut retrouver sur la page omnium studio
dont vous tapez 1 myriam studio sur
facebook et vous allez tomber sur une
super pages qui fait des armures en cuir
et ses garçons aussi vous allez adorer
alors franchement alesi aimé et surtout
comment tu es tu toi aussi tu veux ta
vie en cuir sur la page je vous mets le
lien de la page directement dans le
descriptif comme ça tu me verras ajouté
ce n'est pas que ce sera beaucoup plus
simple
et ouais moi j'ai vu au moins ce qu'ils
ont fait pour toi c'est vraiment cool
merci à vous d'avoir regardé la vidéo
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de
partir parce que le mental blog c'est
une vidéo par jour pendant un an depuis
le 1er janvier donc rendez vous demain à
17h ciao